[Music]
here's your money briefing for Tuesday
March 14th I'm J.R Whalen for the Wall
Street Journal
people with money tied up in Silicon
Valley Bank and Signature Bank that
failed over the weekend breathed the
sigh of relief when the government
announced that their cash Holdings would
be protected by the FDIC so how does the
FDIC work and how would it protect you
if you had cash at a bank that failed
Wall Street Journal personal finance
reporter Amani moiz is here to explain
Amani thank you for being with us
happy to be here so Amani we've heard a
lot about the FDIC in the past few days
and a lot of people probably see signage
for it when they go to their Bank what
is the FDIC and what's its role so FDIC
stands for Federal Deposit Insurance
Corporation which was created in the
1930s after the Great Depression to
restore public faith in the banking
system after a lot of Americans lost
their life savings in a series of bank
failures so essentially it's a
government guaranteeing that you're
going to get your money back if a bank
fails all right and how much of people's
deposits are insured so the Standard
Insurance that comes with any bank is
250 000 per depositor per bank and if
you're a married couple with a joint
account then each individual owner gets
another 250 000 so that joint account is
covered for up to five hundred thousand
dollars all right you know that's a good
cushion for a lot of people who probably
have a lot less than a quarter million
dollars in the bank but what if your
bank goes under like we saw with Silicon
Valley Bank and a few others what does
that look like for depositors even if
they have that insurance policy in place
so when a bank fails and really what
that means is that a bank does not have
enough money on hand to repay all of its
obligations or give money back to
depositors what that means is that the
government will take it over and once
the government determines that a bank
has failed and takes it over you can't
touch your deposits until the government
kind of finishes taking stock and
figures out exactly how much assets that
bank has and with what priority people
need to be repaid so once your bank
fails there is going to be a waiting
period where you're trying to understand
what the government is going to do and
once that's done then you'll be able to
withdraw funds up to the insured limit
it's also important to understand what
isn't covered by the FDIC what that
agency is really created for is to
protect cash deposits so if you have
Investments like stocks bonds those
aren't typically covered by FDIC
insurance but if you have your money in
a brokerage that's very likely covered
by another kind kind of insurance called
the Securities investor Protection
Corporation and though I mentioned bonds
aren't covered by FDIC and U.S treasury
bonds aren't either however if you trust
the US government enough to ensure your
cash then you should also trust them
enough to repay your debt they're backed
by the same creditor effectively okay
but let's say you've done well enough
for yourself that you have a single
account with more than two hundred and
fifty thousand dollars that you've
deposited is there any way to extend
FDIC coverage so you reduce the chance
of losing money well first off
congratulations as you said you're
clearly doing well for yourself and it's
fairly simple to increase the amount of
coverage that you have the most obvious
way to do it is to open multiple
accounts there's no limit on the amount
of accounts that a single person could
have and they're each covered for that
250 000 as long as they're at different
banks the other way to increase coverage
is to have both an individual and a
joint account because as I mentioned
earlier those are insured separately
also if you have a family with some
minors you can set up because tutorial
accounts in your children's names and
each of those accounts would have
another 250 000 worth of coverage wow
and multiple accounts that can be a
handful to follow to keep track of all
your balances the FDIC actually has a
calculator to help you estimate your
total coverage because it can be tough
to keep track of multiple accounts and
stay on top of all the different
statements the easiest way to do this is
to have your bank do it for you and they
do that through a method called deposit
swapping so how that works is you go to
One bank with a large deposit but say
that you want to participate in a
network to have it all covered by FDIC
Insurance what that bank then does is
split up that large deposit into amounts
that are below the limit and separates
them at different banks that way you get
the benefit of having the coverage of
multiple Banks but you're still only
dealing with One bank one monthly
statement or one monthly statement per
product that you end up using all right
that's Wall Street Journal personal
finance reporter Amani movies Amani it's
great having you with us thanks for
having me and that's your money briefing
I'm Jr Whalen for the Wall Street
Journal
[Music]